so most people don't want to talk turn  to Brian stelter to tell us what's real  you are why one of the reasons people  can't stand the media  you're cracking me up don't talk so much  listen more every now and again  something true can actually come through  the airwaves in essence of course what  wolf is saying there is true you stelter  a part of the problem and what does  stelter do he's laughing he's laughing  and then his line is you're cracking me  up you're cracking me up imagine if I  was on air with someone and they just  started full-on assaulting my very  integrity and everything that I do you  think I'd be ready to fight back